[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ont fait l'ultime haute et j'ai 23 ans
et j'étais volontaire l'année dernière
en service civique chez unis cité où
j'ai monté un projet d'éducation aux
médias au sein du programme rêver
réalise l'idée de rêver réaliste c'était
justement de permettre à seize jeunes
porteurs de projets solidaires de
pouvoir monter leur projet durant les
huit mois va pas dû être aussi j'ai 22
ans j'ai fait un service civique à unis
cité à marseille pendant huit mois dans
une mission qui s'appelle coopèrent qui
vise à lutter contre l'isolément social
des personnes isolées qui tend à
favoriser l'accueil et l'intégration des
personnes réfugiées sur le territoire
français je suis omar mora car j'ai 30
ans j'ai fait un service civique à
l'association unis cité donc ma mission
de service civique ça s'appelle cinéma
et citoyenneté notre mission c'est est
de sensibiliser essentiellement des
collégiens et lycéens différents sujets
de société par exemple
discriminations violences faites aux
femmes angie cap et comment on faisait
pour pour sensibiliser on se servait du
cinéma c'est ici que c'est un dispositif
qui est proposé aux jeunes de 16 à 25
ans jusqu'à 30 ans situation handicape
donc permettant à cette même jeunesse de
s'engager dans des missions solidaires
pouvant lui de 6 à 8 mois notamment chez
unicité et justement ces missions
solidaires
permettent d'avoir une action concrète
sur le terrain est telle au moment pour
moi de vraiment découvrir la manière
dont j'ai mis m'investir les gens que
j'aimais bien rencontré ma curiosité
développer mon empathie apprendre à
travailler en équipe on est des jeunes
de différents milieux rassemblés dans
une promo durant les huit mois du coup
qui dit promo de jeunes de partout dit
mixité sociale et ça m'a apporté
humainement parlant parce que j'ai pu
rencontrer des personnes avec qui
potentiellement j'aurais jamais parlé
dans la vie courante nous invite tous
les jours et ça m'a permis de
me forger mes propres idées sur certains
sujets la condition du recrutement
service civique oui c'est parce qu'on a
l'habitude d'entendre diplôme bac + 5
compétences par six compétences par là
non ce qu'il faut c'est juste la
motivation on est motivé pour faire
telle ou telle chose ça suffit après le
reste on avisera c'est un réel tremplin
dans notre vie citoyens pour continuer à
prêts à aller voter allait s'engager il
ya un pourcentage qui dit que
je ne sais combien de jeunes en service
civique mais aux alentours de 90 % je
crois
pense continuer à avoir une action
bénévole ou
autres dans leur vie après le service
civique donc je pense que c'est un réel
tremplin d'engagement et de citoyens